our next speaker has like a few very
interesting things going on
recently became half certified for scuba
diving
it honestly makes me a little nervous
we'll talk about that later
may need to hang out dan chen a little
bit he's a rescue diver you know
and wait wait and then you need your
walk on music and then you recently
learned how to she learned how to make
memes about a month ago she's now drunk
with power
so everyone please welcome sarah okay
folks so
uh
i'm sarah catanzaro i'm a general
partner at amplify partners
uh which does mean that i'm a venture
capitalist not a meme designer
i focus on investing in technical tools
and platforms most specifically data and
ml tools and platforms
but i used to be a data scientist
i most recently led the data team at a
company called mattermark
um
so as a former data scientist and a
current investor like i ought to be good
at predicting things
but i wasn't uh my predictions about
industry adoption of machine learning
like they were very wrong uh
ml driven product development like the
pace of it has been just much much
slower than i anticipated
and so many so many data and ml teams
like they're still saddled with the
exact same problems these are problems
that josh wills
who was the director of data engineering
at slack
described in his talk back in 2016
about the infinite loop of data sadness
so
as a vc like another thing that i've
learned is that like it's never it's
never me it's always you that's the
problem um
so
maybe like i'm not bad at predicting
things like you're just bad at learning
things
hey wes there might even be a photo of
you in here um
so
so like over the past couple of years
like so many early data scientists like
people from
facebook and and like linkedin and in
cloudera and netflix like they've
actually shared a lot about the lessons
that they learned building early data
science products they've given talks on
on you know building ml teams and
streamlining processes and implementing
technical stacks
but those lessons have been largely
ignored
so
for example like back in 2017 monica
regatti she she wrote this blog post on
the data science hierarchy of needs and
she presents this this
set of guidelines for
implementing the foundations that are
necessary to
really benefit from data science and ml
so so for some additional context monica
is now like an aiml advisor she works
with
companies ranging from early-stage
startups to
fortune 500 enterprises
she used to be the head of data at
jawbone and had been an early data
scientist at linkedin
so she's drawing from like a real well
of experience as she writes this post at
end like it is
gold i i swear like if every data team
actually like followed her advice
we would have we would have like flying
invisible autonomous vehicles we would
we would have like
uh perhaps like
headsets that that connected to the
right device when you started a zoom
call or or
um like these things that actually work
but we don't
so
today what i want to do is actually
revisit the guidelines that she shared
and use these guidelines as a framework
to really evaluate where we've made
progress in defining ml stacks and best
practices and where we perhaps need to
course correct
so i will start at the bottom of her
blog post
monica concludes by saying that the
data science hierarchy of needs is not
an excuse to build disconnected
over-engineered infrastructure for a
year
i'd ask you to raise your hands if you
have built disconnected over-engineered
infrastructure um but i don't want to
you know overwhelm the room with hand
phrases uh so many teams have done this
so like how do you avoid it
frankly i think like what more teams
need
is
explicit specific goals for their ml
platforms and goals that they're going
to measure and track
so for example your goal might be to
ship higher quality ml driven software
products
faster in which case you could track
things like iteration speed you could
track things like number of bugs or like
the time to bug resolution but like
we're all data practitioners we ought to
be using data to
track the impact of the tools and
platforms that we use
so with that out of the way
let's start at the bottom of the pyramid
here we have uh data collection um
obviously to implement data science mml
projects you need data
uh that could be like logs or events or
or user generated content or or sensor
data um
no matter what it is like we're pretty
bad at this that's why i gave it a d
um
i'm not sure if anybody else here is
actually from san francisco but you you
might have like heard of the millennium
tower
so it's like this this luxury high-rise
building a like multi-million dollar
project uh that happened in the city but
they built this tower on top of like
soft soil and landfill
so it's sinking
and that's effectively like what we are
doing with data science and ml stacks
today like we are building ml stacks on
top of crap part in my french i hope you
can like
blurp that out um or you know as we
affectionately call it like digital
exhaust
and and our ml stacks are sinking
so
what's going on here you know i think
one of the the kind of more problematic
behaviors that i see is that
data science mml teams they they start
prototyping their models by looking only
at what data is available and accessible
to them and while we certainly want to
use the data that we have we ought to
also consider what we could and should
collect
so why aren't data teams doing this well
first of all you know it certainly
requires us to really thoroughly
understand
how users interact with applications and
to understand application behavior but i
think the thing that is probably you
know scarier is that it perhaps requires
collaboration it requires collaboration
with product engineering teams
who are often implementing this
instrumentation
but if you do collaborate with those
product engineering teams you can do
things like
implement ingestion services
that collect data with a schema that is
actually well suited for your needs you
can do things like adopt uh tracking
plans or like unified log formats or or
event validation systems
that will not just help you collect you
know the right data but also ensure that
certain data quality uh qualifications
if you will
are imposed upon that data
um
what's more like if you are
working with external data if you are
acquiring data from vendors then like
perhaps collaborate with like your legal
and finance team to streamline data
acquisition processes this is going to
make like onboarding new data sets just
so much easier
so i don't want to seem like too
fire in brimstone as i go through this
like there are a lot of data teams that
are doing
super solid amazing work there are also
a lot of people who are working on
projects to solve some of these problems
i'm not actually going to go through all
of these things today
but i'll put the slides online and you
can peruse these projects whatever you
have time
okay so the next thing is moving in
store
um this would be
tools and platforms that enable teams to
collect data from like sas applications
other applications
transmit it to a data lake or a data
warehouse
where it will be stored for downstream
consumption
and the good news is that like we've
actually made a lot of progress here
um
they're all of these new like elt tools
that help you transmit data from sas
platforms and from your like product
applications uh into the the data
warehouse or or data lake things like
multano and air bytes and five tran
those are great
what's more there's a whole new set of
tools like dagster or prefect or
astronomer
that really address some of the
underlying limitations of airflow and
make it so much easier to
orchestrate complex data workflows at
scale
i'm also really encouraged by the fact
that like companies are finally adopting
tools to test and
document and monitor their data
pipelines
and some are even using tools to
understand data lineage
so that they can detect the impact of
data pipeline issues on downstream
services
but i i gave you know this level a b
because like there's this other really
nefarious pattern that i see where
companies are effectively like building
two data stacks they're they're adopting
two systems of record and building
stacks upon each so often i see
analytics teams that are adopting a sql
database or they're adopting a data
warehouse that is optimized for sql
workloads
and working with structured data while
the ml teams are adopting a data lake
that is better suited for working with
both structured and unstructured data
in fact earlier this week i was talking
to
the head of ml at like a fortune
500-ish company and one of these like
multi-billion dollar public companies
who is opining about like some data
governance issues i asked like oh have
you considered adopting a data lake and
he's like no i don't think so later that
day i was talking to somebody on the
bigquery team and they're like nah that
company is one of our like biggest users
so
if your data science team doesn't know
that you have a data warehouse that's
probably problematic
um
but there is like a whole set of tools
many of which have actually come out in
the past year that help rectify this
issue either by integrating the the data
warehouse and data lake or helping you
sync models from the data warehouse into
the data lake or by providing like one
substrate that
is well suited to both data science and
analytics workflows you can check those
things out
all right moving on uh we have the
explore transform level
this is primarily tools to
clean and prepare and like manage the
quality of collected data
um as i as i had said before like over
the past couple of years
uh
with the adoption of of data warehouses
and data lakes and the implementation of
elt
uh platforms like companies they're
storing more data than ever
before uh
but most of this data was not collected
uh for data science and ml use cases so
so data scientists they they need to
spend so much time manipulating and
refining that data until like it is okay
enough to use
and
because this is so tedious i think like
many data practitioners have just
adapted they they've built tools or
they've adopted tools
that make the process of data
preparation like a little bit less
painful
you know tools like dbt
the implementation of like analytics
engineering best practice like
it's making it a lot easier to build
like core data models you have things
like data fold uh that help you prevent
uh data quality issues when you're
making changes to data pipelines or or
your data models
tools like monte carlo
those help detect data quality issues by
modeling the distribution um so that
you're able to
uh
you know gain an awareness of of when
the distribution shifts and things like
that like these things are all great
um
but at the end of the day like we need
to lean way too heavily
on
this set of tools for data preparation
because like we are not being more
careful about data collection and
collecting data that is kind of
purpose-built
for
modeling and analysis
so as pete recommends like next time
you're like
uh toying around with an ml model and it
just won't work like maybe ask a pm to
add a text box somewhere
all right now we are at the aggregate
label
level moving on up
um
here we primarily have like tools and
platforms and workflows for transforming
data into
data products whether it's like
dashboards or reports or stories
uh monica also puts like data labeling
tools and uh feature engineering tools
at this level i think it's kind of like
the data abstraction level or something
or or maybe she just needed somewhere to
slot that in i don't know
um okay
so
we're still really bad at counting like
i
yeah
uh i work with companies that are
building data tools and platforms so
like founders who are former data
scientists former engineers
and even
they like struggle so much with with kpi
reporting
earlier this morning aws actually
released a blog post where they said
that one of their customers was spending
six trillion dollars on rds like six
trillion dollars on rds and the funny
thing was that they reported that like
this was an improvement after that
customer had implemented a more optimal
partitioning scheme so even amazon can't
count
um
so like why why is counting hard do i
think i think it's often hard to
work with disparate stakeholders
to really like figure out what to count
to identify your north star metrics
and when you get there like the work
isn't done you need to
work with them to kind of observe those
metrics and like develop this collective
understanding of
how and why metrics fluctuate and you
know if and when you can influence those
metrics
another thing that i care pretty deeply
about is that like data scientists
should be in the room
where strategic decisions are being made
i can't tell you like how many board
meetings i've attended where like if we
just had more data
or if we just had somebody who could
help us understand the data that was
presented
in context we'd be able to like make
better decisions or diagnose problems in
a more rigorous way so
my hope is that like in the coming years
we will see more data scientists
involved in board level conversations
and lastly as data teams like we ought
to be using our north star metrics too
we ought to be using these metrics when
we think about prioritization when we
think about like the impact of the
projects we're implementing
um the more fortunate news is that like
we do have better tools for data
storytelling and labeling and feature
management
things like hacks and streamlet there
they really enable their stakeholders to
synthesize qualitative and quantitative
insights
and
develop these data stories
that help decision makers
really understand the context underlying
the data but also like improve data
literacy data labeling platforms they're
they're no longer just providing access
to labeling services they often include
tools to think about and assess
data quality and feature management
tools
they'll help you like deal with issues
like online offline inconsistencies or
or accurate backfill
and increasingly they're better
integrated into into data stocks too so
that's good
all right almost there
um
okay so experimentation is like kind of
having a renaissance i feel like more
and more companies are recognizing that
growth doesn't happen by accident that
you need to test more and more ideas to
to sustain growth
more and more executives are seeing
experimentation as a revenue driver not
a cost center
and are in support of deploying
additional resources
to run more tests
additionally like there's a whole slew
of tools both open source and commercial
for feature flagging and randomization
and some new ones too that actually do
things like automate experiment analysis
and help you implement uh techniques
like cupid um that'll that'll like
reduce experimentations
um
the not as great news is that like far
fewer teams are actually using their
experimentation platforms to assess
their ml models
um one thing i am encouraged by though
is that more and more ml leaders are
like picking good problems we're no
longer treating ai as a silver bullet so
they're looking at either like
rule-based systems that have become too
gnarly or like crude models like an
excel spreadsheet
and using them all to replace those and
that's great i think we've also kind of
reigned in the tendency to
use more complex models when a simple
one will do
but it hasn't been fully reined in and i
think one of the the underlying issues
is that like it is still way too hard to
iterate on models in production
if you don't know that you'll be able to
easily replace your simple model with a
more complex one it's going to kind of
like drive a tendency to over engineer
things
so that's not ideal
um
but
why is it that it is hard to refine
things in production i i think like it's
scary because many companies don't
actually have like tools to monitor
their models in production and
if they do they're looking at things
like
f1 scores you know precision and recall
not like the the uh
association between
uh model metrics or model performance
and user experience so we don't really
understand the relationship between the
model performance and like those kpis
that i talked about earlier
um
a lot of the tools associated with
experimentation the tools associated
with mlaps are also like disconnected so
it becomes harder and harder to
uh implement like incremental rollout
strategies whether it's like canary
deployments or or shadow deployments or
things like that and then lastly you
know one of the things that i'm
constantly
reminding people is that like when you
develop a model
you're often only developing like one
component of a software application
you need to connect that model to other
systems whether it's like ui services or
message buses or or databases um and if
it's not easy to like swap in and out
that component then you end up with like
these really brittle complex software
systems that can easily break
but again there are some tools that are
helping to fix this
so you can check those out later
all right we have made it to the top
so
although you know these models are um
nearly impossible to like operationalize
uh ai researchers have actually made
like a ton of progress since monica
wrote that post back in 2017. i i think
it was about two months before she she
published the post
researchers at google brain
uh released the first paper on the
transformer architecture
and it turns out like maybe attention is
all we need
um these models keep getting more
powerful they keep achieving state of
the art
performance albeit on on research
benchmarks as we add more parameters to
them and so like i'm very hopeful that
if we just implement the right
foundations we'll be able to really tap
the potential of these transformer
architectures
okay
so
tldr like collect better data
just do it like
it it will make your life so much easier
over a longer time horizon uh think
carefully about your north star metrics
iterate on models in production and i
guess you know lastly like this is it's
it's a pyramid it's not a shopping list
like these components they need to be
well integrated they ought to work
together
collaboration is key and listen to your
elders we've been doing this for a while
okay i'll see you
later
thank you